joe biden doesn't have much going well
for him
but he'll always have ultra magga
the president doubling down on his
attacks on republicans and donald trump
thinking it will be a saving grace in
the midterms joe ruminating on his
predecessor and coining his new nickname
it's called i called the ultra manga
plan and the ultra maga republicans the
maga republicans are under my
predecessor
the great maggot king
the deficit increased every single year
he was president
the first year of my presidency the
first year
i reduced the deficit
literally reduced the deficit by
350 billion dollars
and if you think ultra maggot and maggot
king slogans are lame well that's
because biden is the guy who came up
with it
people have asked where did he come up
with ultra mega where did he come up
with
what did he call president trump big big
magga i don't know
the king of maga this is all he he is he
is having a good time being out drawing
the contrast and i think he will see
many much more of that and and that i
think will be helpful in sharpening for
the public what the choices are
so jesse i think they just want him to
take the blame for this nobody wants to
touch this thing and hunter aren't
spitballing nicknames from the
you can't magnitude someone with king in
the nickname yes like calling me king
fox okay i'll make it i'm sure
saw this and has like some vicious me
now and mklobe ultra is what i think of
when i hear ultra beer's a good brand
and now i'm thirsty i don't understand
why brandon gets these nicknames this is
a real reach it's not in his natural
remember the neanderthal line that kind
of backfired this is kind of backfiring
i don't get it this was it a fundraiser
for donors now if you're donating to
biden at this point you're an idiot
right so you're going to pay 30 000 to
hear him spout king magga i'd want my
money back but he has to look tough he
has to play the blame game he tried it
with putin didn't work he's now trying
it with magga but mega isn't all about
trump juncken was magga without trump
and he won and many other candidates are
going to do the same thing the senate
republicans aren't maga we know the
truth about that so this thing's not
going to ride and i don't think it's
going anywhere well though uh jensecki
said that he's going out there trying to
create a contrast but the problem is
he's by comparing the present day
reality to the trump past trump keeps
looking better and better because you
don't have inflation you don't have all
these horrible things that are happening
right now in uh in my state in ohio tim
ryan the popular congressman is running
now against jd vance he doesn't want
anything to do with joe biden he doesn't
want joe biden to come to the buckeye
state uh they're trying to distance
themselves and in terms of using you
know to rank out someone to uh to to
smear someone or get a catchy slogan to
uh to put them down uh as my wife says
when the debate's lost slander becomes
the tool of the loser
so uh you know it's uh
my wife
directed at me
so uh
i i i believe that
biden has such difficulty communicating
that even his his nicknames his smears
are ineffective yeah you know uh degan
i've said this before but i got to say
to gay if the republicans don't get like
50 or 60 seats and gain control of the
house senate
then they blew it because i don't think
a moment like this where somebody has
really crapped the bed to quote amber
heard like the democrats
sorry i
you can't find a worse situation for the
democrats than this situation you could
not because every time you say mega the
american people don't think about donald
trump they think about policy
and if you think about what was
accomplished
wages between 17 2017 and 19
increased across all education levels
and the people who got the biggest raise
didn't even have a high school diploma
poverty hit record lows across the
country with the largest reductions
coming for hispanics whites and african
americans i could go on and on about the
policy of magga
not the personality in terms of
personality all i can figure is that joe
biden's trying to be as pathetic as
possible garner sympathy he's going for
the pity vote which does work among some
women and i'm speaking for myself but um
but that's the only possible explanation
for this specter of failure and
desperation no pete davidson i'll tell
you that
you know judge when you look at a lot of
the problems he's facing crime
punishment economy you need certain
perspectives that come with age like
wisdom and experience this is bizarre
because these are some of the areas that
he should be
you know he's past wisdom yeah okay
look this is the man who promised to
heal the nation he was going to unify us
he was going to be the adult in the room
he comes in full throttle trying to
divide the country getting rid of gas
and oil you know defunding you know part
of the defund movement not trashing it
continued full throttle he canceled
today the leases for oil and gas saying
nobody's really interested and you know
the only thing the democratic party is
good for at this point is why and how
were they so quick
to get a bill before congress on
abortion what was it 24 hours 48 hours i
got a bill we've got all kinds of
problems this guy keeps talking about
the deficit you know what nobody cares
about the deficit right now the deficit
they care about is what they're doing at
the kitchen table can i buy food can i
afford to buy gas what am i going to do
all he does is trash people that's like
someone in high school is just just
nobody even listens to them because
because they're full of hate and today i
heard on the news four ms-13 gang
members crossed the border and two
convicted uh child predators sex
predators and this guy's talking about
you know the maggot king and um and how
bad the world uh how bad abortion is
yeah i'm not having i think the the
their abortion bill is their baby
formula um
oh so but you know what they got to
learn to feed the babies and not that's
yeah the other yes that was my point yes
i went to brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now